bienvenidos voy a ponerles un poco al
tanto de todo lo que me ha sucedido pues
resulta que fui a un par de fiestas de
unos bancos muy importantes en nueva
york' y en esas fiestas les estaba
comentando acerca del proyecto de khan
academy y pues esta gente es muy
importante para el futuro de nuestro
colectivo y además para la salud
económica de este proyecto y pues empecé
a sentir como al contarles acerca de
este proyecto sus ojos empezaron a
ponerse llorosos así que decidió ser un
intermedio en los vídeos de física y
matemáticas para hacer algunos vídeos
acerca de economía y finanzas pues
pienso que estas dos materias son muy
importantes para entender el mundo
actual y además cómo se están dando las
cosas en la actualidad y bueno
precisamente no es la idea que esté de
chismoso contando la vida ni las
intimidades de las personas que estaban
en la fiesta porque creo que eso lo hace
bastante bien los periódicos y los
paparazzis así que en lugar de hacer un
vídeo de chismes voy a hacer un vídeo
acerca de contabilidad básica porque
creo que hay mucha gente que no tiene ni
idea de lo que eso significa y la idea
de hacer estos vídeos es exactamente la
misma a todos los vídeos que he
realizado en kant academy sin embargo
esta vez voy a hablar de economía de
final
y de contabilidad y para empezar a
calentar motores en este primer vídeo
quiero hablar de una idea muy pero muy
básica acerca de lo que es contabilidad
en este vídeo quiero hablar acerca de lo
que es un balance general así que vamos
a suponer que encontrado en la casa de
mis sueños y que está vale un millón de
pesos sin embargo para mi mala suerte yo
no tengo un millón de pesos mis ahorros
de toda la vida son doscientos cincuenta
mil pesos y entonces la pregunta
correcta ahora va a ser cómo voy a
comprar esta casa y cómo la casa me
parece maravillosa entonces voy a ir a
un banco a pedirle un préstamo pero
antes de alocarme e ir con el banco
corriendo pedirle dinero lo primero que
quiero hacer es un balance general y
para hacer un balance general lo primero
que hay que saber es que es un activo
por lo tanto cuáles son mis activos pero
antes de decir cuáles son mis activos lo
primero que voy a hacer es definir
activo un activo es algo que me va a dar
en un futuro un beneficio económico por
ejemplo el efectivo es un activo porque
si nosotros tenemos efectivo en el
futuro podemos comprar una casa o hacer
que alguien haga algo por nosotros
no sé comprarnos un automóvil el chiste
es que con efectivo nosotros podemos
comprar una cierta cosa en un futuro por
lo tanto vamos a obtener un beneficio
económico otro ejemplo de un activo es
una casa porque si tú tienes una casa
pues en un futuro no vas a tener el frío
en las noches de invierno bueno pero
como todavía no tengo la casa y de hecho
es lo que quiero comprar entonces cuáles
son mis activos antes de comprar la casa
bueno en este caso mis activos son que
tengo en efectivo 250 mil pesos por lo
tanto hasta ahorita tengo en efectivo
250 mil pesos que son mis activos ahora
vamos a pensar en pasivos que es un
pasivo entonces vamos a escribirlo un
pasivo vamos a definir lo que es un
pasivo y un pasivo aquí está escrito es
es algo que tú tienes la obligación
económica con otra persona o con alguien
más que no seas tú por ejemplo si tú le
pides a alguien prestado una cierta
cantidad de dinero entonces tú tienes un
pasivo de esa cierta cantidad de dinero
porque es un dinero que debes
la cierta cantidad de intereses que te
van a cobrar por haberte prestado ese
dinero otro ejemplo podrían ser los
impuestos si tú le debes muchos
impuestos al gobierno por lo tanto
tienes ahí un pasivo es decir un pasivo
es todo aquello que te vas son deudas
que tú tienes en este caso nosotros no
tenemos pasivo porque solamente tenemos
en efectivo doscientos cincuenta mil
pesos por lo tanto si no hemos comprado
todavía la casa y no le hemos pedido
dinero prestado al banco nuestros
pasivos son de cero pesos y esta es mi
definición de libertad yo soy libre
cuando no debo nada de dinero a nadie
pero bueno ya hablamos de pasivos ya
hablamos de activos
ahora quiero saber cuál es mi capital
entonces vamos a definir qué es el
capital y para esto voy a recurrir a una
fórmula que me va a servir bastante que
dice los activos son igual a los pasivos
más el capital los activos es igual a
los pasivos más el capital por lo tanto
si yo tengo 250 mil pesos de activos y
tengo cero pesos de pasivos
entonces ya sé cuánto es mi capital
porque entonces me queda la ecuación
250000 es igual
pero más mi capital y cero más mi
capital es mi capital y entonces me
queda que mi capital son 250 mil pesos
en este primer caso en este primer
escenario entonces lo voy a poner como
lo ponen en las hojas de balance ya
tengo yo a mi activo y pasivo y aquí es
donde se pone el capital mi capital en
este caso es de 250 mil pesos así que
voy a intentar dibujarlo de una mejor
manera voy a poner mi hoja de balance
como se pone realmente voy a poner un
cuadrado espero que ustedes lo vean no
es muy visible pero bueno tengo mi
cuadrado y por un lado tengo mi activo y
activo son 250 mil pesos por lo tanto lo
voy a escribir aquí doscientos cincuenta
mil pesos de activo muy bien esto es lo
que tengo en efectivo que es mi activo y
mi capital son 250 mil pesos no siempre
es lo mismo en este caso pues si es lo
mismo porque no tengo deudas es decir no
tengo pasivo pero en general el capital
lo podríamos definir como lo que es
lo que es propio es decir lo que me
queda de restarle a mi cantidad de
activo todo lo que tengo de pasivo bueno
esto es en este primer caso hipotético
donde no he comprado todavía mi casa que
tanto me gustaba mi esposa me dice que
no se ven nada las letras que escribo
pero bueno lo estoy haciendo con todo el
interés de que ustedes vayan entendiendo
entonces que vamos a ver qué es lo que
pasa ahora voy con el banco entonces
vamos a dibujar al banco y vuelvo en el
banco y le voy a pedir lo que me falta
de dinero para comprar la casa que tanto
me gustaba este de aquí va a ser mi
banco vean cómo tiene mucho dinero y yo
lo que voy a hacer es éste ir al banco y
pedirle prestado lo que me falta para
llegar a mi millón de pesos
si tengo doscientos cincuenta mil pesos
me faltan 750 mil pesos por lo tanto el
banco me va a prestar 750 mil pesos y
bueno yo a cambio de esos 750 mil pesos
que me están prestando yo le voy a dar
un pagaré es decir en este pagaré lo que
le voy a decir al banco es que yo le voy
a regresar los 750 mil pesos después de
una cierta
de tiempo y además le voy a pagar el 10
por ciento supongamos de interés
compuesto anual muy bien entonces como
se ve ahora me como se ve ahora mi hoja
de balances vamos a dibujar de otra vez
para ver qué es lo que pasó y cómo han
cambiado las cosas
voy a intentar este dibujar un cuadrado
que un rectángulo que sea mejor este va
a ser mi hoja de balance y bueno por un
lado yo tengo lo que es mi activo cuánto
tengo en activo bueno yo tenía 250 mil
pesos pero el banco me prestó otros 750
mil pesos en efectivo por lo tanto en
efectivo yo ya tengo un millón de pesos
entonces lo voy a escribir aquí en
efectivo ya tengo un millón de pesos
bueno después de que fijarnos en el
pasivo recuerdan que el pasivo el pasivo
es lo que debo a una cierta persona y yo
les debo al banco al banco le debo 750
mil pesos por lo tanto de pasivo lo voy
a le voy a poner solamente una p de
pasivo debo 750 mil pesos espero que se
vayan entendiendo todos estos garabatos
que
pero nacional plan es para que ustedes
me vayan siguiendo y vayan poniendo
atención entonces ya tengo mi pasivo
ahora me falta cuánto es mi capital mi
capital nosotros tenemos la fórmula de
activo es igual a pasivo más capital y
si de aquí despejamos el capital no iba
a quedar que son 250 mil pesos de
capital lo voy a poner aquí y creo que
la idea de capital empieza a cobrar un
poco más de sentido empieza a tener un
poco más de idea ya sabemos que tenemos
de capital 250 mil pesos en este caso de
pasivo 750 mil pesos y tengo en efectivo
o me activo es de un millón de pesos
recuerden que estamos hablando de un
segundo escenario y también quiero
aclarar una cosa yo no soy millonario
aunque tenga un millón de pesos todavía
no soy millonario porque hay que
fijarnos en nuestro capital
yo soy millonario porque tengo millón de
pesos pero tengo una deuda de 750 mil
pesos pues por lo tanto no soy
millonario de hecho mi patrimonio neto
serían 250 mil pesos es decir mi capital
es otra forma de hablar o de pensar en
capital como el patrimonio neto lo que
realmente tengo y creo
empiezan a tomar sentido las hojas de
balance pero bueno ya estoy muy feliz
con mi millón de pesos en efectivo y
realmente lo que quería era comprar la
casa por lo tanto gol con el dueño de la
casa y le doy el millón de pesos para
que él me dé la casa bueno realmente no
me va a dar la casa como tal el ex dueño
de esta casa me va a dar las escrituras
de la casa digo en la casa siempre ha
estado ahí pero yo para poseerla lo que
necesito son el contrato social leo el
contrato legal para obtener la casa y no
voy a poner un filosófico al respecto
entonces vamos a regresar bueno entonces
cómo quedaría mi hoja de balance y como
ya estoy corriendo en tiempo y también
en el espacio lo que voy a hacer es
mejor tachar de aquí y en lugar de
efectivo ya no tengo efectivo ahora
tengo una casa que vale un millón de
pesos entonces tengo una casa de un
millón de pesos
y estos son mis activos por lo tanto
también vamos a ponerle el nombre estos
son mis activos yo sigo de enviándole al
banco 750 mil pesos y ojo estoy
suponiendo que la casa realmente me
costó un millón exacto y sigo teniendo
un capital de 250 mil pesos y bueno como
ya estoy corriendo en tiempo entonces en
el siguiente vídeo vamos a hablar de qué
es lo que pasa si la casa aumenta o baja
de precio después de un cierto tiempo y
cómo voy a conseguir más dinero y todas
estas cosas que nos afligen en el mundo
actual